hey guys feed peppers here and making a
how-to video for licorice Larry he's the
he's the bunny looking character here
who is the boss of the mug links levels
and he's the you know the counterpart of
the Queen and cupcake Carl he's our
third villain so far and he's probably
one of the easier ones to understand I
guess if you don't really have a good
idea of how the muggings work make sure
you check out our mullings video I'll
leave the link at the top here so that
you can check that out but Larry does
the same thing we do he tries to catch
his monk Ling's
by collecting the blue light blue or
cyan candies and our job is to collect
ours with the orange so you can see you
the top we have a meter we have to beat
him to 5 and 20 moves we have the clock
time before he collects 5 or 1 out of
note so we're gonna want to drop our
drop our monk Ling down and then we
don't really have to block as much I'd
say like when we're playing the Queen
especially not in this particular level
but it is something that will come in
strategy wise at different times now
there's a couple things that you know
that help that I didn't really it took
it took a while to you know figure out
everything as far as it goes as there he
goes but one thing that wasn't immediate
apparent immediately apparent was that
when when we make matches with blue as I
did right there those don't count
towards his collection and vice-versa so
like whenever
you might see him do something like set
off a color bomb and you know take out
all the orange you would think all it's
a good thing I'm collecting orange but
if you watch you won't be getting any so
it can actually be a little bit
frustrating at times whenever he he does
instead of like doing what you think he
might do like he actually blocks instead
like that I think that's probably the
most frustrating thing like Karl's
frustrating for different reasons and
definitely the Queen can be frustrating
for different reasons but in particular
with Larry when he blocks it's kind of
really annoying because it just seems
like sometimes he's not trying to win
he's um he's just trying to stop us from
running which is all he really has to do
when you think about it so little pop-up
sell me out to collect more and he does
I did collect one of his there that's
not always a good idea but I also got
another one of mine on board and I'm
still ahead so that's something new
you're just gonna want to you know
decide on the fly making you know stun
moves are the same here as they are with
the other two so you do want to make
those in my opinion pretty often but a
couple things to keep in mind there is
that stun moves that collect your
oranges are better than once that dealt
and then when we use our super stun move
after we do three which I'm not going to
be able to do here it doesn't look like
we want to we want to plan it out where
we don't you know where we actually
advance our our monk lines if we can so
yeah like I said I couldn't make another
one there so it's just the way that
worked out but um this is a pretty easy
level so they're not really in trouble
here we have for out and about and all
we really need to do now is collect one
more
and then we can drop them all down and
that'll be that not a whole lot going on
here that's you know strategically
important just sort of just sort of uh
kind of a the board is kind of tightened
up right now so and go ahead and collect
these this should be enough to bring the
last one on the board and now we'll have
four moves and we'll probably want to
make some sort of special to get the
rest of these down we could continue to
make monk lanes this you know if we
collect more orange herbs we don't
really need to on this particular board
this would be good it will get rid of
two of them for us and give us a stun
and then we can finish it off right here
with the purple candies so you see there
it didn't really make a big difference
how many he had you know that there like
I said there's other boards where that
will all right so this is one forty two
and this one is one where we do actually
have to be really conscious of what he's
doing and how and try to stop him from
dropping his down first in the beginning
we're gonna start out pretty much saying
we need to get rid of these blockers so
making specials and getting stuns are
good but it's also kind of tight until
we get rid of some of this stuff so just
try to find the best move first
making stripes is always pretty good for
whenever the for whenever the Mullings
actually get on the board so it's really
never a bad thing to do we do want to
move ours down as fast as we can to
since there's only one orange square
here so you know we want to we want to
make sure it's clear for the next one to
come out right away so we don't lose any
time when we're clocked in nice to get
Cascades his sides kind of all smashed
up right now so can kind of just focus
on our side he just did a little block
in there
that's a good combo force so we have
three and you can see he already had two
so you can see that it's a little more
you know it's a little more since these
fell out pretty fast and you get him on
the board pretty fast it's a definite
possibility that we could if we're not
paying attention to what he's doing that
he could actually get his on the board
too fast and we would lose like where
he's not just playing to stop us but he
could actually win
they weren't pretty good shape though we
got both of them on the board already he
still only has three so those we don't
make any major mistakes here we should
be good this would be helpful if he
doesn't mess it out every once in a
while he'll have he'll on up helping us
some because what you know his side of
the board's messed up it doesn't it
doesn't happen as much as like when
you're playing Carl though for sure yeah
so this is a mess down here let's see if
we can he kind of messed up there I
don't know if he knows that but all
right so just need to get this off we
got three moves so what can we do here
the bottom is just a mess
all right it's a to move this will work
as long as he doesn't mess it up for us
there we go so you know Larry he's
pretty cool he's a little different than
the other bosses but there's same basic
concept just have to approach his levels
a little different always you know kind
of figure out how many oranges it takes
to fill it up fill up your meter see how
many how fast they're coming out try to
figure out in the beginning whether
you're trying to you know actively block
him and watch out like take his colors
off the board and stuff like that and
then just you know plan accordingly like
I said I hopefully this will help and
you'll give it a like if you found it
helpful and subscribe to my channel to
get access to all the latest how-to
videos and level videos as soon as they
come out thanks